and back here at home the Nevada
Department of Motor Vehicles is working
and trying to address this long backlog
of appointments Mary Jane beliesza
reports on what's caused it how the DMV
is working to fix it
Kevin Gonzalez is back at the DMV only
to learn the process has been delayed
again my appointment is November 19th I
was supposed to have the title before
February 27th and now
um you know it's a month later Gonzalez
wonders of staffing issues or something
else is causing delays it used to be a
one-day service he'd come in you know
now you have to wait in the line Kevin
Malone with the Nevada DMV says it's a
work in progress as of February 19th we
had 52 vacancies in the Las Vegas field
offices and another 46 in the northern
field offices
fourth and that's a total of 173 for the
Department however it is a lengthy
process to get new employees behind the
desk it takes eight weeks to train a TMD
technician once they've been hired and
about half of that is actually sitting
on the Windows serving customers with
really close supervision and then the
other half of it is in the classroom
Malone says jobs aren't always posted
the DMV takes resumes and vets the
candidates anyone can send us a resume
explaining what they want if they're
looking for a Frontline technician then
the more formal job openings are listed
on the careers.nv.gov website another
issue causing frustrations at the DMV
when people don't show up to their
appointments one factor is we've got
about a 45 percent no-show rate for
appointments it's recommended you cancel
your appointment online if you can't
make it Malone says the Nevada
legislature is considering raises for
Allstate workers he hopes it'll go
through other state agencies pay a
little bit more than the DMV for similar
jobs and the state government as a whole
typically pays less and we do what we
can to try to keep people
it sure has been frustrating for a lot
of people so the DMV is also
recommending you check if your service
can be done online before even making
that appointment